the new horizon spacecraft is one of the
fastest things we've ever launched off
the surface of the planet the new
horizons spacecraft is traveling about
14 kilometers per second another way of
putting that is about 36,000 miles per
hour and even at that it's taken us nine
years to cross the distance between your
food 0 crossing 3 billion miles of space
that's a that's a hard thing to picture
this is really just opening a door to a
whole new realm there's the third realm
of the solar of our solar system which
is Pluto and the Kuiper belt the very
best images of Pluto are so pixelated
they're so poor because of the great
distance three billion miles by the time
we get our best images back from New
Horizons they be it equivalent if we
were flying over New York at the same
altitude of looking down on Manhattan
and not just seeing Central Park but
counting the ponds in Central Park and
the wharfs on the Hudson our data rate
to the spacecraft right now since it's
so far away it's one kilobits per second
because it's five hours of light time
away from where we are and with all of
the data that we're taking through the
few days leading up to the Pluto flyby
and then a few days afterwards it's
going to take us a whole year to
download all of that data it's been kind
of interesting over my entire career you
know which is the most favorite planet
of everybody is Pluto all ages all walks
life everybody loves Pluto